take a deep breath we take 23,000
breaths a day trying to get oxygen to
our brain and cells oxygen is essential
to our survival but it's only a small
percentage of what's in the air we
breathe so what if there was more of it
but it caused giant insects to roam the
streets with everything catch fire would
it make you superhuman these are just a
few of the things we'd be dealing with
if the Earth's atmosphere had double the
amount of oxygen it has today what else
would happen this is what if and here's
what would happen if Earth's atmosphere
had double the amount of oxygen our
atmosphere contains about 20 percent
oxygen and roughly 78% nitrogen
even though oxygen is not the most
significant part of our atmosphere it is
the most important ninety percent of our
body's energy comes from oxygen with the
rest being from food and water you
wouldn't be able to watch this video
without oxygen you wouldn't be able to
do anything that's because you wouldn't
be alive and not only is oxygen
essential for humans it's vital to all
life on Earth now what would happen if
the earth had doubled the amount of this
crucial element the first thing you'd
notice will probably be those giant bugs
insects breathe through tiny tubes
called trachea scientists have theorized
that if more oxygen were to enter these
tubes insects like spiders and
cockroaches would grow much larger about
300 million years ago during prehistoric
times Earth's atmosphere was 30% oxygen
during that time insects were much much
larger dragonflies were the size of
Hawks while some spiders were the size
of small birds doubling the Earth's
oxygen levels would mean having even
more oxygen in our atmosphere than they
did back then our insects would be even
more enormous although these giant
insects might scare the pants off you
you can feel better knowing that you'd
have the energy to outrun them with a
higher oxygen level you'd notice you
have much more energy the human
endurance records of today would quickly
be shattered after everyone gets more
oxygen
you'd also be more alert more oxygen in
your body improves your circulation and
increases your energy humanity would
seem much less diseased and you'd call
it sick a lot less or would you a type
of infection-fighting immune cells known
as neutrophils would occur more often
keeping you healthier you'd get a lot
fewer colds you'd be like Superman well
not quite
the increased amount of oxygen your
body's getting could also lead to some
serious long-term health problems with
increased levels of oxygen humans would
have an increased chance of oxygen
toxicity this happens when humans are
exposed to higher oxygen levels than
their bodies are normally used to over
time this could lead to lung damage poor
eyesight and cells not being able to
reproduce having too much oxygen in your
body creates free radicals these atoms
look for other electrons to pair up with
when this happens it can cause damage to
your body and your DNA oh yeah and what
about all those crazy fires we mentioned
well with more oxygen in the atmosphere
things would catch on fire more easily
generally speaking when you can't start
a fire it's due to the lack of oxygen
with there being even more o2 in the
atmosphere think how easily everything
would catch fire I think California
forest fires are bad expect those to
happen all around the world even wet
vegetation would have a chance of
burning and as for the planet as a whole
well for one we'd have a lot more mass
oxygen isn't just in our atmosphere it
also plays a large part in the Earth's
crust and with more oxygen the crust
would be heavier making the lithosphere
heavier than our atmosphere this would
cause things to oxidize including large
bodies of water turning into hydrogen
peroxide
so some good and some bad comes from
this but luckily you can take a sigh of
relief knowing that our atmosphere only
has 20% oxygen and so far it's worked
out pretty well for us but imagine if we
had no oxygen well that sounds like a
story for another what if
[Music]